[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
takes off outside the dotted line and
making shot at work and at the last
block shot giannis
jonas plays both ends of the four
defensive player of the year because of
plays like that
[Music]
wow drew holiday
kicks it back out lopez tucker
finds it to the cupboard once again
and brooklyn needs time out a multiple
pass sequence
holliday lopez tucker and then giannis
for the emphatic finish
[Applause]
just been more alert
[Music]
he gave him a great lift what a great
pass
out of a double team by giannis to
tortoise he's doing it again 11 of 15.
what a great pass by otto google
great ball rotation middleton giannis
[Applause]
and then drew makes a good decision ball
switch sides
and janna's coming downhill look out
a really nice touch he gets around the
basket he seems like he
plays well off of one foot
[Applause]
oh gosh with a pass making a hard hammer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
slams at home the pace though in the
second half has been to the liking of
the los angeles clippers wow
who got blocked under dunk diana's
shaking his head
saying not here so it looks like he's
loose
and you see giannis come over and say no
sarah twice on the pipes here
uh huh when you see a guy going with
that kind of force
and that's a learning swing for giannis
too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful lob as giannis runs to the rim